speed reading there's two parts of  reading there's reading speed and  there's comprehension there are five ops  to close to effective reading first  obstacle is lack of education how we  read is usually how we first learned it  second optical lack of focus a lot of  lack of focus is because they're reading  too slow let's say you're driving in  your neighborhood  drinking your coffee texting thinking  about dry cleaning you're doing five  things where you're going slow but if  you're racing cars you're not thinking  about the dry cleaning trying to text  you're checking yourself in the mirror  you're focused on the act of driving and  what's in front of you speed gives them  the focus the focus gives them retention  the comprehension